okay hello everyone welcome to another
episode of science and technology q a
for kids and others
and i see we have all kinds of questions
saved up or arriving from our
form on the web
let's see i see one here from kade
how does an easter bunny lay eggs
i think that one is uh
is um
challenging i think that the uh
uh
the
the myths that led to the eggs
are different from the myths that led to
the easter bunny but probably sometime
in in history they merged i mean it's
always a little bit um
uh you know from nursery rhymes on
it's always uh a little bit um
uh terrible if you try and decode what
these nursery rhymes actually mean
they're often
things that
uh were quite um
they're not as
even necessarily as g-rated as one might
think back in the past
um
i i certainly remember well
there's things like you know the humpty
dumpty sat on a wall that one is not too
bad but that one i'm pretty sure
was a uh what is it all the king's
horses and all the king's men couldn't
put humpty back together again i believe
the original humpty dumpty was some kind
of siege machine that was used in the
english civil war in the 1600s and when
the the humpty dumpty
uh was
was pushed off the wall of the city that
was trying to
scale um it uh
uh
the the
as the nursery rhyme says all the king's
horses and all the king's men couldn't
bit humpty together again
of course it's probably the case that
there are three other origin stories for
that mystery ride and it's serious work
to try and figure out what's correct
um i know another one that um
uh again i'm not always certain which
ones exist in different places around
the world but at least in england and i
don't think i've learned these things
since i was a kid and i guess my kids
were big enthusiasts for some of these
so i didn't learn from them but um the
the ringer ring of roses pocket full of
posies etc etc etc
um that one has terrible origins in the
in the black death
bubonic play
in england in the 1660s i think
um and it's kind of a
prescription for
um in a sense how not to get sick and
what happens if you do get sick type
thing so these things leave these
traditions have a have a habit of having
you know origins and history and then
they get quite distorted so i don't know
the the full easter bunny story um
i think that uh uh the whole
easter story is always kind of
interesting from a science point of view
because you know there are some holidays
like uh christmas day for example
december 25th okay in the in the
standard kind of um
uh
you know western christian tradition
um it's december 25th is christmas day i
think in other
um
oh if i'm not mistaken
in like uh greek orthodox russian
orthodox
uh
traditions i think it winds up being
like in january may january 7th or
something
but it's always on a fixed day of the
year um easter on the other hand
switches around which day of the year
it's on
because easter has a much more
complicated method for computing when it
should be because it's based on the
lunar calendar rather than the solar
calendar when
the the days of the year
as we name them from january 1st to
december 31st
are
uh ultimately based on thinking about
how the the sun the how the earth orbits
around the sun
and at what point the earth will come
back to the same place it was before
after one
year
it's always a little bit tricky whether
it's a tropical year or other kinds of
years after one year one says the the
earth has come back to the same place
that it was
before in its orbit around the sun and
that the time it takes for the earth to
come back to the same place
isn't a whole number of days
it's not 365 it's 365
i think
um so it's it's roughly 260 365 and a
quarter which is what leads to our leap
year convention because instead of
saying there's a quarter of a day per
year which would be very inconvenient
because then we'd end up with sort of a
time zone shift for our days instead of
doing that we kind of fix it up every
four years by saying there's a leap year
but that isn't quite right this is not
exactly 365 and quarter it's a little
bit off that and so then there has to be
this extra convention that was
introduced in the 1500s of having a um a
missing leap year every 100 years and
then an axe extra one every 400 years
and so on to kind of keep the uh
rotation of the earth
aligned with this calculation of when
the earth will be back to the same place
and sort around the sun
but when it comes to easter it's based
on lunar calendar that is it depends on
how many times the moon has gone around
the earth moon goes around the earth
roughly 13 times in a year that's uh
leads to a lunar month of roughly 28
days i guess um but it's not exactly
that
and uh it's a a complicated piece of
calculation to figure out when the moon
is going to be in a certain position and
actually the calculation of the date of
easter is one of the early kind of
difficult mathematical calculations that
was uh being done
in uh in in the 500 years ago or more
so it's a it's a it's a tricky thing to
work that out and it's it's in different
traditions around the world
there's sort of a mixture of luna solar
etc calendars
for particularly for holidays and so on
um so it's it gets to be a kind of
complicated thing
anyway i don't think that explains
anything about um
uh
the easter bunny in its and its eggs but
um perhaps interesting anyway
um
all right let's see
another question we have here from from
means
question is what is the planck
temperature the limit of potential heat
and how does it relate to the limit of
potential
all right let's see that's a that's a
kind of a physics question so let's
let's dive into that
so first of all what is temperature so
temperature
is
the
the energy with which
molecules for example in a gas
or any other material are
the the energy that the molecules the
average energy that the molecules and
gas have
so
the when you heat things up what it
means is you're putting energy into the
material and that means that the
particles that make up the material are
running around more and more quickly
they have higher and higher kinetic
energy energy of motion
so
the um
uh
and so what happens is that you know uh
the standard thing we see with typical
materials
is that we go from the molecules are
not running around very quickly and
they're all getting stuck together and
the fingers are solid the molecules are
running around more quickly it becomes a
liquid
eventually the molecules are running
around so quickly that they don't the
forces of attraction between them are
not enough to kind of pull them together
into a into a blob of stuff like a
liquid and they just become a gas
okay so
what you might think is okay you can
keep going and just heat the thing up
just keep heating it up forever and ever
and ever
and so what goes wrong if you start
making things hotter and hotter so for
example
i don't know the temperature of the
center of the sun is perhaps 10 million
degrees centigrade
um that's pretty hot
that's also the kind of temperatures one
needs if one is trying to make uh fusion
is trying to get hydrogen um
atoms to fuse together to make energy um
either in a in a fusion reactor or in a
hydrogen bomb um one needs millions of
degrees centigrade
of of energy and what what happens at
millions of degrees centigrade is that
the hydrogen atoms are going so quickly
that the fact the hydrogen atoms the
nuclei hydrogen atoms normally repel
each other electrically
you overcome that force of repulsion by
the things just ramming together with
enough speed that they can then uh merge
and produce a lot of energy when they
fuse
so
the question is when you heat things up
how hot can you make things
well
uh
the
well all kinds of things might happen
when you make things very hot
uh so
one of the one of the issues is
um
if you make
let's see how to explain this
the
a couple of different things
um
so when you have a lot of a lot of heat
that means there's a lot of energy
somewhere so some little piece of gas is
really really hot means it has a really
large amount of energy
okay so one of the things that happens
when you have a lot of energy
is
it's that produces a lot of gravity as
well
so normally we think of gravity as being
oh the earth has a big mass
and so it will gravitationally attract
anything to that mass
and the sort of simplest formulas for
gravity just say the gravity
is proportional to the mass of the of
the object that
is the the
the two masses of the objects multiplied
together
but
in fact there's an equivalence between
mass and energy and gravity is also
produced by energy as well as by mass
so you know famous formula is equals mc
squared the energy
is equal to the the the
total energy of something
if it at least if it's staying still if
it isn't moving around total energy is
the mass
times the speed of light squared
um and
let's see we can
um
that most of the time
so
energy you take an object and just move
it around it'll have a certain energy
associated with motion that energy is
roughly a half
times the mass times the velocity
squared that's the standard formula for
kinetic energy
but
the
there's also an intrinsic energy
associated with the object
and if you were to somehow
get rid of the mass in the object
then you could convert that to a certain
amount of energy so for example the
place where that happens
is uh
let's say you have an electron and an
anti-electron or positron
and you let them annihilate each other
they can they can interact they can
analyze each other and they can produce
two photons
and so then in a sense you're you're
taking the mass let's say you just got
this electron
and the positron and they're just
hanging out near each other actually
there's a weird thing called positronium
which is a kind of atom where the
nucleus of the atom the puck's nucleus
is a positron a positively charged
analog of the electron and then there's
an electron sort of going around outside
it uh positronium uh
is
can be stable but if you just have the
electron and the positron sitting there
and they just sort of amble towards each
other there's no real velocity involved
but eventually they they come
sufficiently close
that they react and you end up getting
two photons out
okay so in that case you're converting
the rest energy of the electron the
positron to the pure energy of photons
photons have zero mass
and so sort of everything that is there
is just the energy of a photon not its
rest mass
and so that formula e equals m c squared
tells you the energy of those two
photons that were reduced by the
annihilation of an electron the positron
at rest
um but in general the the full formula
um if you're into these things
is um e squared equals p squared c
squared plus m squared c to the fourth
so what that formula says is the energy
uh is has a term that depends on the
momentum
and it depends on the rest mass
and so the total energy of something
depends on how much it's moving around
that's a kinetic piece and it's
intrinsic energy associated with the the
rest mass of the thing
okay so as far as gravity is concerned
it doesn't really care very much
where the energy is coming from whether
it's coming from rest mass or whether
it's coming from momentum it basically
treats those as kind of the same type of
thing a little bit different in detail
but basically the same kind of thing and
those are both sources of gravity
and so
in the the sort of official version of
this is einstein's equations
which uh represent gravity in terms of
the curvature of space-time and the
curvature of space-time is proportional
to a thing called the energy momentum
tensor which is sort of a combination of
energy and mass and momentum and so on
but in any case the basic bottom line is
um energy like mass
is a source of gravity okay so imagine
we have this gas in a box
and we heat the gas up really really
high temperature it's going to have a
lot of energy that energy is going to be
a source of gravity
and so what will happen is that as we
make the energy sufficiently high
that though there will be so much
uh the the
the the the energy associated with this
gas will be such that it will produce
there'll be a huge amount of gravity
associated with the energy
of this gas
and eventually it'll get to the point
where there's so much gravity
that
it
uh basically makes the space around the
thing kind of implode on itself so how
does that happen
so and essentially form a black hole
so what happens there well
the
the
the more gravity there is
let's say there's an object that has a
certain mass
and it has a certain size it has it
produces a certain amount of gravity on
its surface
and now you ask the question how
difficult is it to escape from that
thing so you fire a rocket up and you're
trying to get away from the gravity of
that object
how fast you have to go to escape the
gravity of that object for the earth if
you go more than 25 000 miles an hour
you will escape from the gravity of the
earth and you can have a spacecraft that
goes at that speed it'll it'll if you go
more than that speed you can just
wander off into the into the into the
rest of the solar system or into into
the rest of the cosmos so to speak for
the sun
um it at the surface of the sun
the escape velocity is somewhat bigger
it's 100 000 miles an hour so that's the
speed you have to get to
if you're going to escape from the
gravitational pull of the sun from the
solar system for example i think for the
um
uh for the whole galaxy it's about a
million miles an hour
but in any case the the question is if
you have an object that has enough mass
uh concentrated in a small enough area
uh small enough volume
the
the gravity is such that the escape
velocity will get larger and larger and
larger and eventually the escape
velocity is more than the speed of light
and since you can't get something to go
faster than the speed of light that
means nothing can escape from that area
and that's what it means to form an
event horizon which is what defines a
black hole you can you can't nothing can
escape from that event horizon because
if you try to fire a rocket out
you the fastest you could ever fire a
rocket out will be at the speed of light
but even things at the speed of light
are pulled back in by the gravity of
that object
so if you make something sufficiently
hot
you would eventually get to the point
where there will be so much gravity
produced by the energy of that thing
that you will end up forming a black
hole
and uh that's that's sort of a limit on
how on the temperature that you can
reach for for things
and
the uh
well
let's see that that's uh
there are other limits to temperatures
so one of the questions is
it what will happen
to space-time for example if you just
make it if you put more and more energy
into space time what happens
well in our models
we can
let me think about this for a second
uh
yeah i think
i mean i think what happens is basically
you form lots of you form little black
holes or other much more bizarre
features of space-time um you you're
essentially having it having to be the
case
so so roughly the reason this happens
is
uh
in our models of space
from our physics project which we think
really is how physics works
at the smallest scales space is just
made of a giant network of points we
have this idea that space is sort of
continuous we can move around anywhere
we want but in our model of physics that
isn't the way it works instead there's
this underlying structure
at a very very small scale trillions of
trillion trillions of meters in size
there's a very there's a structure where
space is kind of giant network of points
and
uh what happens is
if you say well what's the shortest path
from one place in space to another
through this kind of network
um well
if
in in many cases that shortest path is
basically just a pure straight line
but what happens is that energy
is associated with the amount of
activity in this network so this network
is continually getting rewritten in fact
that's kind of how space is knitted
together it wasn't for the fact that the
network is locally getting rewritten all
over the place the different parts of
space would never communicate with each
other and we wouldn't have something
that is behaves like space that we can
move through and so on
but in any case it's sort of continually
being netted together but the rate at
which it's being knitted together in any
particular region of space
is in our models determined by the
energy
at that place in space
so the higher the energy the faster the
rate of kind of rewriting space
that that is happening and so that
process of rewriting
means that if you look at the shortest
path from one place to another it is
deflected by all that rewriting that's
going on essentially if you were to look
at kind of what's the fastest way to get
through the network from one place to
another if there's a lot of little
pieces of network in there and a lot of
sort of density of network then it's
kind of it um uh you you're kind of you
tend to want to go through that place
where there's more network in some sense
and that's that's why these the the sort
of the shortest path is deflected and
that's kind of ultimately the
explanation for the reason for the force
of gravity and the deflection of what
are called gd6 shortest paths in space
so in the case where
you have
a sufficiently high energy density all
kinds of crazy things will happen with
those shortest paths
and i'm not absolutely sure what
uh
what would happen if you just inject
more and more you just rewrite this
network faster and faster and faster i
think what will happen is just that the
shortest paths will all get captured
into that region where everything's
going to be written it's like all the
action in the universe is going on just
in this one place
and so kind of all paths that you follow
um will just get
dragged to that place in the universe
and that's that's sort of what will
happen as you try and make the
temperature um incredibly high to put an
incredibly large amount of energy there
now the actual value of the temperature
you need is some ridiculous trillions
and trillions and trillions of degrees
centigrade to achieve anything like that
but that's i think the final thing that
happens
now there is one
funny thing
uh in the very early universe
uh temperatures
well were effectively a lot higher
uh maybe i shouldn't explain that but
that's that's a different story perhaps
but maybe one other thing to mention
about temperature
um
in
so when you heat things up
there are
you're
you're effectively as as things are
going faster and faster
boys this can be easier to explain i'm
going to try and tell you about why
people thought at one time
there might be a maximum temperature
and not associated with this effect
about gravity and making black holes and
things like that but a quite different
kind of maximum temperature
and
yeah so the idea is this
the
normally you say well i've got a bunch
of molecules and they're bouncing around
and we're making it hotter
eventually
those molecules things will get so hot
that the energy that's that's um
uh binding the electrons in those in
those
binding the atoms and the molecules
together
the electrons to the nuclei of the atoms
you'll have so much energy associated
with things bouncing around and
colliding with each other and so on that
you will no longer be able to keep the
electrons bound to nuclei of atoms and
the things will get torn apart into a
plasma that's what fire is is a is a
plasma where the where the um uh
nuclei of atoms have been separated from
their electrons so that's the first
thing that happens
um
now
the
the question is you might think when
things are sufficiently hot oh it's just
a bunch of nuclei bouncing around
but here's a weird thing that can happen
uh let's say that
as you
that there are various ways to make new
kinds of particles
not let's let's say that you have so so
when you heat things up
uh normally you go from you know
ordinary matter to plasmas
and if you heat things up even further
so the plasma you've torn the electrons
away from the nuclei of atoms
so if you go to even higher temperatures
you will start tearing the nuclei of
atoms apart and in particular you can
kind of tear apart the pieces of protons
and neutrons
and so what what happens is you get
what's called the pork gluon plasma
what's inside protons and neutrons are
quarks and these gluons which are
particles that that get exchanged
between quarks that kind of pull the
quarks together to sort of bind them
into a proton or something so at
sufficiently high temperatures you get
this kind of pork blue on plasma that's
the current belief about what happens
and that's been observed in some
particle accelerators at least to some
extent uh you get very very small
amounts of pork blue and plasma for very
short amounts of time you can kind of
tell that it's this kind of blob of of
stuff at a very high temperature um
and uh okay so that that's what people
think happens
now
uh but nevertheless you've gone up to
this very high temperature everything
has turned into a bunch of quarks and
gluons um but
the question is what would hap
you have this high temperature and the
energy associated with temperature is
just going into the kinetic energy of
the particles it's just making these
particles maybe it tears apart the the
the atoms maybe it tears apart protons
but it's still basically the energy that
you keep on putting in just goes into
making particles running around faster
and faster
okay there's one weird thing that could
happen what if there are more kinds of
particles that you could produce
and what if as you put more energy into
the system instead of that energy going
to particles running around it goes into
making new kinds of particles that have
higher masses
so i remember i said that the mass and
energy have this equivalence that's
that's what e equals m c squared is
telling you that tells you that you
could take like that positron and the
electron and they could annihilate each
other produce sort of pure energy um at
least the photons that don't have a rest
mass
um you can also go the other way around
you could take those photons that are
just sort of energy no rest mass
and
and have them interact and produce an
electron and a positron that have a mass
so just as you can go from mass to
energy so you can go from energy to mass
and so as you pump
more energy into this system that is
uh at a increasingly high temperature
you would might think that all the
energy you pump it in
is making just the particles run around
faster and faster but there's another
possibility which is if there are more
kinds of particles you can make you
might just be making new kinds of
particles rather than having that energy
go into your existing particles running
around faster and faster and there was a
model back in the 1960s
when people
had different views about how particle
physics works there was a model which
said that the number of kinds of
particles should increase exponentially
with their mass
so in other words as right now we know
about some number of kinds of particles
but there will be more and more and more
and more particles and and as you
increase the the mass the numbers of
types of particles that you would get
would just get incredibly much larger
so
i mean in fact that theory
uh was somewhat related to string theory
which is a has been kind of a popular
mathematical development in mathematical
physics in the last particularly 30
years it's sort of related to that
um the uh the buzzword for this is the
hagedorn temperature
um but the idea was that instead of
energy going into making uh particles go
around faster and faster the energy
would go into making more particles and
what could happen is if you have an
exponentially increasing number of kinds
of particles you eventually will get to
the point where the more
that you you try and put more energy in
and all you'll get is more particles
more new kinds of particles produced
not
uh
not something which is is sort of
traditional temperature with kinetic
energy so that's a different form of
maximum temperature that doesn't seem to
be the way that it actually works
um
let's see
uh
the question from wobin here is
void space really void or is there
something there
uh
there's no notion
i believe of space
unless in a sense there's something
there
so in our model of physics for example
space is made of this giant network of
points
and
in order for us to for example move
through space in order for a spacecraft
to go through space there kind of has to
already be
some network of points there otherwise
as the spacecraft the spacecraft itself
is just a feature of space it's like
when you have water for example you've
got all these molecules bouncing around
and they make up the water and then you
can have a vortex you run your finger
through the water this is the whirlpool
going behind your finger that vortex can
move through the water
even though that vortex is is ultimately
just made of a certain configuration of
the underlying molecules but that the
the the an electron or a spacecraft for
that matter going through physical space
it's a it's kind of the same sort of
story there's an underlying structure of
space that's like the way that the
molecules make up the the structure of
water and then there are features of
that that we notice like electrons or
spacecraft or whatever that are like the
vortices in the water
so in order for the vortex to be able to
go through water there's got to be water
there that the vortex is going to be
made of and so it is with space
that there's no way to kind of expect to
move around in space
unless there's already space there for
you to move into so to speak so you're
kind of like the vortex
operating you know on this background
there's all these little points in space
all connected together in this network
and the network is continuously changing
and so on so space
empty space is actually an incredibly
active place if you were to look at it
at a very small scale not that you could
look at it in the ordinary sense of
looking but if you were to at least kind
of conceptually imagine what's going on
there it's a place of incredible
activity at a small scale just like in
the water there's incredible activity of
all these molecules bouncing around even
though all you see is that vortex going
across the surface of the water
and so if it wasn't for all that
activity in space space would not be
knitted together there wouldn't be any
way to move from one part of space to
another there wouldn't be anything to
move into there wouldn't be any anything
to sort of for you to be
when you move to that other part of
space
and actually one of the things that's a
little bit sobering is it looks like the
fraction of the activity that's
associated with all the things we care
about electrons and spacecraft and all
that kind of thing
is just
one part in a trillion trillion trillion
trillion trillion trillion
maybe or more
of the actual activity in space
so the vast majority of what's going on
throughout the universe is simply the
netting together with the structure of
space and we're just a little piece of
kind of froth on top of that is
everything that we care about
so
that's in our new models of physics
that's kind of how we think about it
uh it's it's been known actually for
nearly 100 years
that
there is
activity in space i think there's it's
much clearer now what that activity is
and that that activity is actually
necessary to create the structure of
space
but it's been known that there's sort of
stuff going on even in a vacuum in empty
space that's been known for 100 years
it's been known ever since people
started figuring out that out about
quantum mechanics
and what's been believed is that there
are so-called vacuum fluctuations
um that
in
that at all times
there are always
uh virtual particles being produced and
being created and annihilating all the
time everywhere in the vacuum
and in the end
that claim is probably equivalent
to the way that our underlying models
work for space although i think our
underlying models for space
are much in the end much deeper models
but that's kind of that's you don't get
quite up to the froth that we can you
know that we care about with the
electrons that we actually see and that
move around and so on but it's but the
the kind of traditional quantum
mechanics
is a layer just below that
then there's this giant ocean
of stuff which is what our models talk
about that's below that the really low
level kind of machine code of the
universe that's below that but if you go
almost up to the surface of things that
we care about you get kind of the
traditional ideas of quantum mechanics
of which the most uh
well the one i'm mentioning here is
vacuum fluctuations
so
what happens is
that
in
well let's see
the the sort of standard description of
this
is in a vacuum there are
virtual pairs of particles and
anti-particles that are continually
being created and destroyed
what that means is
in
in standard physics
there are properties that something like
an electron has it has a certain mass
let's say
and
because of the mass it has a certain
relationship you can compute its energy
you can compute its momentum based on it
moving around and there's a certain
relationship between energy and momentum
that's determined by its mass
um in fact that um that formula i was
telling you before e squared equals p
squared c squared plus m squared c to
the fourth
that is the relationship between energy
momentum and mass
um so
and
for an ordinary electron they just pick
up
you don't really pick up electrons
because they're too small but an
ordinary thing a particle um that exists
and that can move it go around the root
universe
it has a certain relationship between
energy momentum and mass
um okay
but it turns out that according to
quantum mechanics
particles can exist that do not have
that relationship
they are what's called in a it's called
their off their mass shells and that's
that that's a bit of a bit of a weird
mathematical statement um and uh
you think about the um
uh you can think about these things in
terms of vectors and you can think about
the uh the length of the vector it's a
four vector the length of the four
vector uh the square the
is is determined by the mass and that's
why when you say if the length of a
vector is is a constant then that's
corresponds to the vector sort of
tracing out the surface of a sphere and
that's why this phrase on its mass shell
comes up
so when an electron has its ordinary
relationship between energy momentum
um it's said to be on its mass shell and
it is it's just an electron that can go
around wherever it wants
but according to quantum mechanics for a
very short time an electron can exist
that does not have the ordinary
relationship between energy momentum and
mass can be off its mass shell that it
can have pretty much any energy in any
momentum
but but the amount that the time it can
exist for gets shorter and shorter the
further away it is from having the usual
energy momentum mass relationship
and
that idea of particles that are
uh that don't quite have the usual
relationship that's the idea of virtual
particles
so a place where virtual particles are
important
is let's say you have an electron two
electrons
and
they are just going along an electron
can emit a photon
and that photon and then that photon can
travel to the other electron and that
photon has momentum so the the photon
can essentially give a kick from one
electron to the other and that's so it
can transmit a force from one electron
to the other but that that photon
doesn't exist very well it's emitted
from one electron and it's absorbed
moments later by the other electron and
because it doesn't exist for very long
it doesn't have to be a real photon it
can be a virtual photon that has a weird
relationship between energy energy
momentum and in case of photon zero mass
it can act like a photon that doesn't
have zero mass it can act like a photon
that has some huge mass
um because and it can do that according
to quantum mechanics but only for a very
short time and the larger the effective
mass the shorter the time that it can
exist for so it's kind of like you can
quantum mechanics says you can make a
mistake about the mass
um and but not for very long eventually
your mistake will catch up with you
and so
in um
uh
let's see in in the
so there's this idea of virtual
particles
and
that you can have things which
completely kind of mess up these energy
momentum mass relationships but only for
a very short time so in particular they
can mess it up to the point where you
can have an electron or positron created
out of empty space
um and they can exist but only for a
short time they can they can you can
create that mass but only for a very
short time you can create the mass of an
electron and a positron
but and so you're you're kind of
violating the usual principles about how
that should work but you can do it but
for a very short time
so everywhere in the vacuum there are
little virtual
uh particle anti-particle pairs being
created and then destroyed and there are
you know there are there are sort of uh
ones of higher energy that last for even
shorter times that ones have lower
energy that lasts for longer times but
that's happening all over the vacuum
and
it's supposed to be vacuum but it's
actually got all these fluctuations
going on now those fluctuations are a
kind of junior version of the story that
i'm telling about the the sort of
rewriting of space the rewriting of
space is a lower level a much more
intense process
than this particle antiparticle thing
essentially what's happening is the
particles are like little things like
vortices on the water they're like
little features of space
and so what one's saying in quantum
field theory which is the kind of theory
that talks about virtual particles in
quantum field theory what one's saying
is that there's continually activity
going on
in the quantum fields have this activity
that is kind of a shadow of this much
deeper activity that's going on in the
structure of space according to our
models in any case in quantum field
theory they're these virtual particles
that exist everywhere in space
uh the significance of them
is not much at all in one field there
it's just they're a thing that's there
in our models that go deep below quantum
field theory those virtual particle
phenomena are incredibly significant
because they're the things that make
space possible they're the things that
create the structure of space
but in traditional quantum theory um
they're just things that happen to be
there
the um the the uncertainty principle uh
which is a general principle in quantum
mechanics about uh how precise you can
make things
um basically says that
nothing can be made absolutely precise
in quantum mechanics
including counting how many particles
you have there's always some error in
that and that's why there will be
virtual particles that's one explanation
of it anyway bottom line is the virtual
particles in the vacuum everywhere
okay one question is can you tell
one embarrassment is there are so many
virtual particles that in the very
traditional version
of quantum field theory
uh the one that people have sort of
believed in the last hundred years
um there is there are so many of these
virtual particles they create
they would create
lots of sort of bubbling energy in the
universe
and that energy would be enough to
create a huge amount of gravity which
would curl the universe up into a tiny
ball
and so one of the things that has been a
mystery
is why vacuum energy as it's called does
not basically destroy the universe
and in our models we kind of understand
why that is it's because that thing that
one's describing is vacuum energy is
actually what makes the universe
actually what makes the structure of
space
and so it's it's not that you are just
handed all this activity in space that
already exists which would cause that
space to kind of curl up in a tiny ball
it's that that activity makes the
structure of space
okay but in traditional quantum field
theory um what
is the effect
of um uh the of these all these
fluctuations in the vacuum well there
are all kinds of effects and people have
measured some of those effects probably
the most famous is the thing called the
casimir effect
and um here's how it works it's kind of
a weird thing you take two metal plates
completely in the vacuum two metal
plates they don't have any electric
charge nothing like that two big metal
plates you put them in a vacuum and
there's a small force of attraction
between them very weird
so what is that caused by what it's
caused by is that there are vacuum
fluctuations that are happening between
the metal plates there are vacuum
fluctuations that happen outside of the
metal plates
but the presence of the metal plates
basically restricts the kinds of vacuum
fluctuations that can occur between them
roughly what happens is that when there
are these virtual particle anti-particle
pairs produced
roughly
the lower the energy
the kind of the bigger the virtual
particle anti-particle pair ends up
being sort of the the greater the extent
and the ones that have very low energy
don't
uh they just don't fit between these two
metal plates if you have a certain
distance apart so some of the low energy
vacuum fluctuations don't occur
um
in between the metal plates but they do
occur outside the metal plates so that
means there's there's all those high
frequency high energy fluctuations
happening within the metal plates
they're also happening outside
but there are some low energy ones that
are missing between the plates but still
exist outside so what does that do that
means that there's a pressure pushing
the plates together because those
fluctuations on the outside are there
they're not there on the inside so
there's this imbalance and the plates
get pushed together so that effect is
small effect but it's observed
now
turns out
uh you might have thought or people
thought for a while
in the 1930s
people thought that maybe electrons
were
held together by this tasmanian force
but it turns out when you work out the
cascading force for a spherical object
bizarrely instead of it being an
attractive force it's a repulsive force
and it just kind of tells you that the
math is a little bit more complicated
than what i was just telling you that's
that's just a way of thinking about it
that works out well in that case
there's another effect so it's called
van der waals forces or london
dispersion forces
those are forces that are very important
in in chemistry
um that are forces that
hold
that the force of attraction between
neutral uh neutral atoms
so
it um if you just have two atoms
um in just hanging out
and they don't have any electric charge
on them that there's still a force of
attraction uh between them and it's
associated with
something to do with vacuum fluctuations
it's a little complicated what happens
is there are vacuum fluctuations that
kind of elongate one of the atoms
and cause it to have an electric dipole
moment they cause it to separate its
positive and negative charges and that
separation of positive and negative
charges induces a separation of positive
and negative charges on the other atom
and then those two sort of separated
positive negative charges have a little
force of attraction between them and
that that's a very important thing in
kind of
in in holding materials together the
so-called van der waals forces and they
are ultimately can be thought of as
being the result of vacuum fluctuations
kind of causing that sort of temporary
uh sort of separation of charge in atoms
so that's that's a little bit of a story
of um uh of what's in the vacuum
um
lots of stuff the vacuum the vacuum in
some sense has everything in it just
bubbling around and we are simply seeing
when we see material objects and
particles and things like that we are
seeing kind of
the just particular features of what
exists in at least in a virtual way
everywhere in the vacuum
let's see
well there
um
okay there's a there's a question about
about space does that mean there are
more dimensions of space than than we
usually think of yes the answer is yes
in these models of space where
everything is just a network connecting
points together
um there's no reason for that
connectivity to lead to something that
is like three dimensions like you're
moving around in this network you can go
anywhere on any one of the network
connections and it could be the case
that on average you will have just three
different directions in the network but
that doesn't have to be that way and
certainly on a sufficiently small scale
it will not be that way you will not see
the the three dimensions is sort of this
emergent thing on a large scale on a
small scale it won't look like that and
when the universe was was young uh you
know shortly after the beginning of the
universe when the universe was small and
the big bang um when the universe
started expanding i think it's very
likely that the universe was infinite
dimensional that the universe was a
network that's very very very connected
so you can go in any direction there are
many an infinite number of directions
you can go in and from a number of
separate directions and then gradually
as the universe kind of expanded and
pulled down then it got to the point
where space only had on large scale
three dimensions but on a small scale
there isn't really even a definition of
dimension but you can think of it as
being sometimes even sort of much higher
dimensional than space normally is maybe
lower dimensional as well there isn't
really a definition until you get to
sort of a large scale it's just like if
you say what's the density of water you
say well on a large scale they're this
number of molecules in this volume of
water but if you go down to a small
enough scale you'll be looking at these
tiny little areas and say oh a molecule
just went by or another molecule went by
and you won't be able to say you'll say
well the mass divided by volume which is
what density is um the amount of mass in
this volume uh right now it's a whole
three water molecules oh at the next
moment it's seven water molecules it
keeps on fluctuating around and it's the
same thing with dimension when you look
at these networks and so on
um
well let's see
uh to go fairly soon here let me see
there's something that i can
um
try to answer here um
there's a question from aaron that i
don't know the answer to it's asking
from how many discrete stars was our
earth made
um
our earth
as
the fact that we have heavy elements
like gold anything beyond iron in the
periodic table
is a sign that
uh
the
our star our sun our solar system was
not a first generation thing in the
universe
at the beginning really all one will
have is hydrogen and the production of
heavier elements is the thing that has
to happen in things like supernovas star
explosions
and uh
uh that's so we know we're not
first generation so to speak we know
we're not freshly made from the stuff
that the universe originally started
from
um
and uh
the um
uh but
exactly how many it's a very interesting
question actually i don't know the
answer to that how many distinct
stars
sort of were
were sort of pulled together to make the
sort of primordial cloud of stuff from
which our solar system condensed
and i wonder if there's any way to tell
uh
the only way i can imagine is the
relative abundance of various isotopes
different uh variants of of
of elements where there are different
numbers of neutrons in the in the nuclei
i don't know i i don't know the answer
that's an interesting question
um pritz is asking can we tap the
casimir effect for energy okay i'll tell
you a funny story here so back in 1981
i wrote a paper with a friend of mine
named jan ambion um about casamay energy
uh was a paper called
properties of the vacuum part one
mechanical properties we had a part two
which was electrodynamic properties we'd
advertised a part three about
gravitational properties which we never
wrote and and yan because he was uh
had an alphabetically earlier name the
mind just kept on getting requests over
all these years for 40 years getting
requests where's part 3 of this set of
papers
and i realized with our physics project
now
we could actually write i actually know
how to write a part three um
i think uh i'm still working on on uh
anyone to to understand what we're doing
enough to be to be up for for making a
part three of this thing john himself
has worked on actually the discrete
models of space time with a slightly
different kind that i think are
equivalent to ours but that's a
complicated story but anyway
okay so we wrote this paper about
properties of mechanical properties of
vacuum and looked at this casimir energy
phenomenon
uh for different kinds of
uh quantum fields and different
configurations and we looked at
particularly boxes that are like
cuboidal boxes okay and you put
a field quantum field
in those boxsters and you say
is the force on the walls of that box is
it attractive or repulsive
um and depending on the shape of the box
the force law the the forces are
somewhat different and as you change the
shape of the box the forces change in
this very strange way
and so we had this picture that i made
with a you know computer calculation
back in 1981 of the forces
uh as a function of the shape of the box
okay so a few years go by
and a physicist and science fiction
writer named robert ford looks at this
picture he says wait a minute i can take
that picture
and i can make a closed cycle where i
take this box and i change its shape to
this to that i can make a closed cycle
of of uh of sort of shapes of the box
just like you would have in a car engine
or something you would have a closed
cycle of you know you open the cylinder
up you fire something you push the
cylinder down it's a it's a cycle that's
a very typical thing to look at in
machinery is some kind of cycle so you
can imagine the cycle of a box that's
just sitting there in a vacuum
okay so what what he noticed was that
based on our calculations if you went
through this closed cycle you could
actually extract energy from the vacuum
so he wrote to me and said is you know
is the calculation really right
i think so you know according to um uh
it's a long time ago but but um
according to you know the physics that
we know this calculation is right
although there are some approximations
that you're using for representing this
box which are kind of questionable
anyway so
so then
the conclusion from that is well you
could extract energy from the vacuum
and so this idea of zero point energy
and zero point energy as a method for
for example uh propelling spacecraft and
so on that became a thing that was
discussed in a bunch of nasa workshops
et cetera et cetera et cetera and people
tried to measure the effects and the
size of the effects and so on but the
thing to me whatever it's life in
science it's life in science fiction has
been excellent and i'm i'm always kind
of amused when when in some
uh movie or something there'll be some
device that is uh said to work using
zero-point energy
because that came out of that um that
work that we did on on the casimir
effect and zero point energy now does it
actually work no it does not actually
work and the reason it doesn't actually
work is that
to make it work
you have to have a box
that can kind of contain
every possible thing that a quantum
field does
and the problem is that you make a box
out of metal for example it has atoms
the atoms are a certain distance apart
the atoms have a certain energy binding
them together et cetera et cetera et
cetera it can it can it can kind of uh
constrain it can it can keep inside
contain
um a certain
range of things the quantum fields can
do but not all of them there will always
be sort of very high frequency very
little jitters in the quantum field that
will always get through between you know
you've got a metal box you've got atoms
of the metal there's a certain distance
apart you know maybe uh
a uh
a
tenth of a billionth of a meter or
something apart um but nevertheless
there will be a little jitter in the
quantum field that's even smaller than
that so it can get through
so there's no material you can make the
box out of
that will cause it to be able to contain
the quantum field in the way that you
would need in order to be able to do
this closed cycle of extracting energy
from the quantum field
now as i'm talking to you about this and
i'm thinking about part three of our
series of papers which we never wrote um
about uh i haven't written an academic
paper since 1986
um i've published what i do in different
ways um but in any case the um
i think um
uh
the
as i'm thinking about it the one
interesting case where you could expect
to make things like this work is if the
walls of the box in a sense are the
event horizons of black holes
so if you could make something where you
contain the quantum field
inside essentially a black hole and
you're distorting the shape of the black
hole
then that will be a different story now
you know at the first level that's kind
of a
loser of a story because yes you can
switch around the black hole maybe
and you can have the vacuum energy
inside it change
but it's like it's inside a black hole
what are you going to do with it you
know you could say i've got a lot of
energy in there but it's inside a black
hole and i can't get my hands on it
but it's a little bit more complicated
than that i think
and i have a suspicion that there is at
least in principle
there might be a way that's an
interesting thought there might in
principle be a way of mining energy
from
the vacuum
and what how do you get you know what
does it mean to mine energy from vacuum
what would that mean
it would mean that
you're gradually taking some of the
activity of the network
that
knits together the structure of space
and you're turning
that energy that's just knitting
together the structure of space
into organized energy
that can for example correspond to the
motion of electrons or the motion of
atoms or something so it's very much
like what you have to do so so one of
the things about the sort of fundamental
results about thermodynamics
um
which comes in many forms but one form
of it is heat does not flow heat flows
from hotter bodies to colder ones in
other words you have all these molecules
bouncing around in a hotter body they
can make molecules in a colder body
bounce around more by transferring some
of their energy but the colder body
can't somehow make
it that you you don't sort of transfer
heat the colder body doesn't get colder
and transfer its heat to the hotter body
and another version of that is to say
it's difficult to take heat and make it
into mechanical work
and why is that well it's because the
molecules are all bouncing around
randomly but mechanical work like moving
a piston is about taking a bunch of
of molecules in the piston and having
them all move together
it's kind of a way of of um
and so the question is to what extent
can you get all these molecules that are
randomly bouncing around to do something
that is systematic and move the piston
in a systematic way
and it's the difficulty of doing that
is the difficulty of extracting sort of
energy from heat it's extracting useful
work from heat and that's kind of when
you make a steam engine or something
that's that's the big thing that you
achieve is to take heat and extract
mechanical work from it so i think what
one's asking for here and extracting
energy from the vacuum is the same type
of thing can you take the heat of the
vacuum so to speak all this random
motion not motion really although all
this random rewriting of vacuum
rewriting of the the structure of space
can you take that and can you organize
it into
uh actual things that we can recognize
as particles going around with certain
energies velocities whatever else so
that's really the question it's really
the extraction of of useful work
from the vacuum i think is very much the
same kind of thing as the extraction of
useful work from a sort of random gas
with a certain temperature so the
question then is how would you go about
how would you make the analog of a heat
engine so that's that's the name for the
the type of thing that a heat engine is
something which just
takes heat and turns it into mechanical
work
um so the question is what is the analog
of a heat engine
in the case of space time and is there a
heat engine that can take the vacuum
fluctuations in the in in the universe
and turn them into useful mechanical
work that's an interesting question i've
not thought about it that way before my
guess is that there is such a thing and
that you can at least in principle
imagine constructing it using uh well
things like black holes
um and an interesting question how that
would work it's a good uh good thing to
work out um and uh
actually i think this um
analogy which i hadn't really considered
before telling you guys about it right
now um about um
uh sort of the
the
the idea
of what it takes to go from
sort of the the random structure of
space to something systematic
um
that's kind of
a um
that that that gives a very close
analogy between
uh well what's the second law of
thermodynamics a phenomenon i call
computational irreducibly and these
questions about extracting energy from a
vacuum that's an interesting thing so
that's a that's a piece of technology if
there's a way to do it
i think it's a few hundred years in the
future
um but uh it's and sometimes it's kind
of a terrible thing because you know you
can realize that there's basic science
that allows you to see how something's
possible and then you realize we are so
far away technologically from being able
to do this
i mean the great example of this is when
isaac newton figured out about laws of
motion
uh in like 1687
it's like from that point one could have
known and and i think he knew that you
could in principle have a a satellite
that would orbit the earth but it took
until 1957
until that was actually put into
practice so
a uh you know sort of almost a 300 year
span
so it's um it's one of these things
where it's a little bit funny to be able
to see these things which are in
principle possible but then it's so far
in the future um to actually be able to
achieve them and some things maybe even
further because it may require uh you
know it it may require energies and and
so on which just are far away i mean to
make a rocket
requires kinds of things that that uh
make a rocket that will reach orbit
requires kind of um a way of making sort
of explosive energy that certainly did
not exist in isaac newton's time i mean
i guess fireworks existed but they are
it's it's a bit of a far cry from a
firework to a uh to a satellite launch
um but it took took a while to have that
happen
um
parker is asking uh
constraining uh vacuum fluctuations
using some sort of field
um yeah the problem is
that um
a
uh a field
has the same features so sometimes for
example in in um
uh in constraining a plasma
to uh sort of squash it down to be able
to achieve nuclear fusion you can use
magnetism you can use a magnetic field
to do that
it doesn't have the same problem of just
having atoms and things escape from the
atoms
but what will happen is
in
uh
for this case of dealing with vacuum
fluctuations the problem is the field
that you use to constrain it
will also have this difficulty but it
has only certain
um
essentially frequencies of um
uh um of activity in it and there'll
always be pieces that can escape
with the possible exception of an event
horizon in gravity which is a little bit
of a different situation and that's a
possible case where you could do this
constraint and that's in a sense a field
it's a gravitational field but it's a
gravitational field that has very weird
properties
about
essentially
well maybe you could do it another way
too um
yeah okay so with an electromagnetic
field electricity and magnetism
um
that electric the magnetic fields don't
hold themselves together you can make an
electric and magnetic field you can put
it somewhere you can you can produce it
in some region of space but the field
itself does not affect that field the
field itself an electron can affect the
field but the field doesn't affect the
field for gravity that's not true
gravity affects the gravitational field
so because the gravitational field
itself effectively has an energy
and that energy has an effect on gravity
the gravitational field affects the
gravitational field it's a nonlinear
process where gravity affects gravity
and that's what allows you to get things
like black holes where the intensity of
gravity affects the intensity of gravity
there's another case we know where that
happens which is in the gluon field that
holds um the quarks inside things like
protons that's another case where there
is this linear effect
um where the field affects the field
and so i am wondering although it's
uh oh that's pretty funky actually um i
am wondering whether there's a possible
way to use court glue on plasmas and to
use that non-field
um to make some kind of uh
sort of constraining bottle but i don't
think that would work because i think
that the problem is that anytime you
have a a size of field that is
constrained by a by a certain a certain
sort of size that you understand
that size will never be able to catch
all the little jiggles of the vacuum of
the vacuum fluctuations that are of all
possible sizes so i don't think that can
work but it's a will be an interesting
thing to analyze properly
all right lots of interesting physics
today i have to go as a matter of fact
for those interested i'm i'm going back
to my day job here and we've got a live
stream doing a design review of some
more from language features
um i do want to make the plug that for
people who actually want to sort of dive
deeper and understand how to do science
and
and uh discover things in science and so
on um you know use wolfram language it
is the the thing i just spent the last
40 years building to make it possible to
discover things in science
and uh uh you know i have lots of fun
discovering things in science so lots of
other people with it and uh it's a it's
a really good thing to to learn
for the purpose of understanding science
and exploring science and
even if you're a pretty early stage
you've got a tool set that is very
powerful and lets you kind of jump ahead
and discover things that people never
had a chance to discover before
and i'll i'll make a final plug for the
elementary introduction of language
which is a book that i wrote which
you'll find three on the web um and a
good thing to start with if you haven't
already done so um
all right we should wrap up here
thanks for joining me
and see you another time